- I say him.
- Yeah.
'Cause it seems like he'll
plan something secretive
for you.
(women agreeing)
- Definitely.
That TLC love.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] If you had to
rank yourself against others
based on a specific
trait, what would it say
about how you see them?
And how they see you?
We brought together five couples
and had the boyfriends rank themselves
based on how attractive
they think they are.
Then, we invited their
girlfriends to rearrange them.
This is Ranking.
- My name is Kalvin, I'm
23, and I grow cannabis.
- My name is Ryan, I'm 25.
I work for a tech company.
- My name's Dominic, I'm 21.
I'm a full-time student, and
I'm working in tech consulting.
- Hi, my name is Marc
Vega. I turn 28 today.
I'm a YouTuber, a real
estate agent, and an actor.
- My name's Micah, I'm 21.
I'm in the process of getting my license
to drive the commercial
trucks and big rigs.
- [Narrator] Who do you guys think
they will find the most
attractive in the group?
- I would say this one.
- This guy.
- He's like, six foot.
- I thought Dom was, just
based off a first impression,
I thought he would've
been ranked the highest.
- 'Cause he had the
looks, he had the height,
he had the eye color.
- I was gonna say Micah.
Just the style, the hair. Seems chill.
- Can I say myself? I'd say myself.
- Confidence, man.
- Hell yeah!
- I was gonna say, you look
like Andrew Garfield, kind of.
- Oh, I get that one a
lot. Actually, yeah, yeah.
- I just realized, you
look like Edward Cullen.
- Oh, I've gotten that before.
- Yeah, I see that.
- The guy from Twilight?
- Yeah!
- I can see that.
- Alex Wasabi.
- Oh, man.
- We're gonna get this every day.
- By the way, I like the beard.
I like the beard, it works well on you.
- I like the hair too.
- Dude, I can't grow a beard.
- Did you get a fresh
cut just recently, too?
- Yeah, two days ago.
- I knew it, I knew it.
- Had to look good for the cameras.
- I like your hair. I love your hair.
- I usually get a fade
right here, like, zero,
but I just put my hair down.
- I'm jealous, I love his hair.
- Yeah, yeah, I do too.
- [Narrator] Do you guys
think your girlfriends
found you attractive
right when you met them?
- I would say yes,
'cause, first day we met,
we actually kissed already.
- When I first met her, she was working
at this restaurant, and she
asked me out on a date, so...
She definitely thought I was attractive.
- I'm not sure, actually,
'cause she kinda low-key
almost left me on read
and almost didn't respond
to me after I started talking
to her in the very beginning,
but I think she finds me attractive
'cause I help her dealing with emotions,
I know that's a big thing,
and I'm kind of like
her partner for that.
- We had a great first
date, so I think so.
I showed up really edgy-looking,
like I had a sword piercing earring,
I was wearing all black, but yeah,
these days I feel like
I dress more like a dad,
so, you know, times have changed.
(upbeat music)
- One is the most attractive?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, get over there.
You deserve to be there.
- Number two.
- I was thinking keep this one number two,
'cause I just like the beard,
you got a beard and everything.
- I don't know, I'm very
firm on number two with you.
- Yeah, I was gonna say two for you.
- Two.
- You can be there.
- So should I move?
- Yep.
- I think you should be here.
You look like Alex Wasabi.
(men laughing)
- Number three it is, then.
- That's fair.
- Yeah. I agree with that, yeah.
- I think I might be in the wrong spot.
- Why? Why?
- I think I gotta scoot
that way a little bit.
- Oh.
- This guy!
- It's a toss-up for me.
- It's a tie.
- 'Cause you look like
Andrew Garfield, kind of.
And he looks like the dude from Twilight.
- Oh, there you go. Oh, now I see it.
- Yeah.
- I would say it's one,
two, three, four, five.
- I could agree with you on that.
- So, my ranking would honestly
be, I think you, Micah, two.
Three, four, five.
- Yeah, one, two.
Probably put you at three, four, five.
- Then what would you say?
- I would say one. Two, three.
I'll do four and five.
I'm cool with being anywhere
between three to five.
- I got two and three the
most, I got three more.
- I got four.
- [Narrator] What if we did a ranking
based off of only personality?
- I'd say you one for personality.
- Yeah, you're really funny.
- You two move up, you're in front of us.
Push us two down.
- You two should go up.
- We can still figure out the order.
But you two definitely up.
- Do you think you're one?
- That's a toss-up for me too, you know?
I like your personality,
you're pretty cool.
- I think he should be up too,
'cause you're really chill.
- Yeah.
- Me?
- I was thinking that, too.
I would move you up in front of me.
- Okay.
(men laughing)
- Probably, I'm pretty quiet.
- Yeah, you are pretty quiet. That's why--
- Confident, though.
- It comes from my girlfriend.
She gives it to me.
- I really think Micah should be one.
Based on looks and personality,
I really do think Micah should be one.
If we're combining both, I really do.
- I think he has a pretty unique style.
(men agreeing)
- So you want me to stay here?
- I think he should be two,
'cause he was really confident.
- This guy?
- All right, move along.
- Go, go, go.
- It's hard for me to rank you below me.
I'd be happy to switch.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Do you think you should be number four?
- Honestly, my personality
sometimes lacks, so yes.
- Sometimes lacks? Okay.
- [Narrator] Is this your final ranking?
Are you guys happy with this?
- I'd say so.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
(slow music)
- For me, it's more than
physicality, obviously.
- Yeah, for sure.
- So, personally, I wouldn't
be attracted to him,
off the bat, but he talks really well.
Like, the way he talked about you
and the way he presents
himself was really sweet.
So I would rank him up top for sure.
Maybe like, one or two.
- Okay, so, number one, of course.
Number two, because of his hair
and we're the same color, so, automatic.
(women laughing)
I honestly put him as number
one for the most funny.
- Yeah, I agree.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Who?
- You know, birthday.
(women laughing)
- Obviously, my man, number one.
- Good.
Number two, I say him.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause the way he comes out,
he seems so friendly
too, seems like the type
of guy that would be just
a nice boyfriend to her.
He seems like he'll plan
something secretive for you.
(women agreeing)
- Definitely.
That TLC love.
- I'm gonna go with my boyfriend first.
(women laughing)
Pretty biased, whatever.
I think he should give
himself also more credit,
so I give him second.
He has a personality, he
has a good personality.
But I also like Kalvin.
- Yeah.
- The way he said, "I learned
my confidence from you."
- Yeah.
That was really sweet.
- Yeah, Ryan, number
one for me, personally.
Number two, plaid shirt,
I just like the style.
It's something that I think
I would honestly wear.
And also funny, such a bright personality,
like you're just naturally
attracted to his essence,
which is really cool.
(upbeat jazz music)
- Okay.
No hard feelings, I think
everybody's beautiful
and gorgeous.
Number one, specifically because the vibe,
the jewelry, the head bop when
he was listening to music.
Number two because of the
way he presented himself
and talked about his significant
other was just so cute.
Number three, funny, outgoing, happy.
Number four, kind of quiet, but fun.
And then, number five, no hard feelings,
no one's a five in my eyes, but that was
in just my personal taste.
- Number one, I mean, what a stud, right?
Number two, just really
love the hair, the style.
And super funny.
Number three, the style,
very cool-looking.
Four, kind of energetic,
he's got some vibe
that seems really cool, mysterious,
you kind of wanna know more.
And then, five, still very attractive,
just not my type, to each their own.
- He's number one because
I think he's very cool.
Number two, I think he should
give himself more credit.
Number three, I don't know
a lot about his personality,
but from what I've seen, he's really cool.
Number four, he just
looks like a kind guy.
And number five, he is attractive,
but attractive is subjective.
- First one, not being biased.
I just find him really funny.
Two, great personality, great person.
Third, he has an Edward Cullen look.
Four, sweet guy.
Five, he has a lot of confidence,
but I don't personally
find him attractive.
- Number one, I put...
Because I find him really attractive.
Number two, I put... as a tie
because one, I feel like
I kind of like the energy,
but I wouldn't really be attracted
if I spent a lot of time, but
the other one I felt like,
attractive but not really, I
don't think I could hang with.
Number four, just not it for me.
And number five, I'm not interested
in the topics I learned about that person,
so I don't really wanna listen to it.
Thank you for coming to my TED Talk.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Kalvin,
we're gonna move you--
Well, switch spots with Ryan.
- Personally, it is what it is,
I'm only trying to impress one person,
so it didn't really bother me too much.
- [Narrator] Ryan, let's
switch spots with Dom.
Dom, let's switch spots with Marc.
And lastly, Micah, switch spots with Marc.
And that is your average
score from the girls.
- Oh shit.
- I thought it was you!
- I thought it was you.
(soft music)
- I thought I was gonna
be three or four honestly,
just 'cause I knew I was
lacking a little height.
But, I guess they mess
with my vibe, I guess.
- I never thought I was gonna
be ranked number one. Never.
And I really thought Dominic
was gonna be number one.
- I don't know, I think they
just appreciated my hair
and the fact that I
look like Edward Cullen.
That definitely helped me a lot.
- I'm still shocked I'm here.
I'm really, really shocked.
- [Narrator] Is anyone
sad with their ranking?
- The girls spoke.
(people laughing)
- The women have spoken.
- [Narrator] Don't worry guys.
You guys get a turn next.
- Uh oh.
- Oh, shit.